welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the book
of event episode six from the desert
comes a stranger an episode ironically
filled with familiar faces familiar
music familiar trauma so filled that
boba fett is really back to his ot
status of sulking silently in the corner
yet still still i cannot help but squeal
like a gamorian at all this nostalgia
porn because there's actually so much in
this episode that is easy to miss trust
me in a deeper meaning to why we are
seeing luke and grogu jedi hour on this
boba fett series so let's break it down
you know i've spent more time pouring
through this episode than anyone down to
the point of just staring at vfx luke's
lips also you can get this awesome boba
vet inspired shirt exclusively at
newrockstarsmerch.com it's really the
best way to support new rockstars and
get your hands on this great design
before it goes back in the starlock pit
so we open on the spinning veins of a
moisture evaporator now in engineering
of these vapor spires the veins really
serve as a humidity sensor a way of
determining how much moisture on the day
can be coaxed from the air and condensed
in water through these chilling bars so
these veins spinning wildly isn't just
classic western imagery foretelling to
storm a bruin it's literally a prime
moisture collection day here on the
outskirts of mostpelgo town a matter of
life and death for these desert dwellers
all interfered with because of this
stupid drug deal two ways the pikes are
threatening tatooine and must be stopped
these pikes keep the spice in the same
kind of chest that we saw in episode 2
and their credits are kept to the same
kind of cam tono storage unit used
throughout these series based on the ice
cream maker prop carried by wilrow hood
on cloud city and empire strikes back
good ol willrow always gonna get a shout
out every time one of these things shows
up combat the booth river very thin
return to the mandalorian chapter 9
stepping into freeman that classic
western gunslinger shot hand already on
his blaster the same frame that they
used on han solo in a new hope when he
approached jabba the hutt originally
deleted from the 1977 cut added back in
a special edition cobb says and these
stripes
indicate i'm the marshal of said
territories yeah those red stripes on
white is the same insignia on the
marshall badge captain carson tiva gave
cara dune minus the new republic icon
meaning these stripes are a widely
accepted symbol of authority in the
outer rim the pikes choose violence and
he takes down three of the four but
notice he only actually fires twice the
first shot taking out two of the pikes
the second just taking out the third guy
but the way those last two were lined up
he could have gotten them both something
this final pike realizes as cobb tells
him i can see you're the smart one
yeah probably an involuntary gesture
from timothy oliphant but the wink means
the same kind of thing like trust me but
i'll also kill you also that gusty
opening shot also showed how this is a
perfect windy day for scattering some
spice dust taken off the streets flowing
downwind probably some bantha who is
high as a kite now mando pilots his
custom n1 starfighter to the planet
where luke brought grogu after we last
saw them in the mandalorian season 2
finale now to be clear this planet is
not identified it is the same planet
where luke had his school the one
destroyed in the last jedi flashbacks
but that planet was deliberately never
identified in star wars canon like this
is not alfrana that was a rocky or world
that luke and lord santeka visited with
ben solo years after this in legends
after the empire fell luke did build a
new school in yavin 4. but the audio
description this episode just calls this
a verdant planet and i think if it was
yavanpur they would say so like we don't
see the massive red main planet of yavin
that you have before orbits as a moon
there's no temple of massache anywhere
folks like the many sightings of
gibberish auravesh in the show sometimes
it's okay to just not have an answer yet
in mando's cockpit the controls were all
recreated from when anakin piloted one
of these in phantom menace but remember
with anakin they were red because that
fighter was initially on autopilot for
him but they shifted to blue when r2
released the controls as they are now
with mando also you'll notice the radar
navigation is now on the left instead of
the right and pele added that booster
switch and there's also a new display in
orange and red in the upper right with
orbesh that translates to att psi psi
being a unit for pressure maybe an
adjustment for the exposed droid port
now being closed off in a jump seat
although when mando lands it hops out
briefly the camera does frame r2 back in
the canopy of that port r2 greets him
i assume those beeps translate to hey i
once piloted one of those naboo star
fighters with the future war criminal
whose son is now the dean of the new
school we're building a life crazy mando
sees a boulder rising we think by itself
or behind the ridge as if maybe luke or
grosgoo might be doing some rock force
bench press in like luke did on dagobah
instead this is actually in the
mandibles of an ant droid a new form of
tekken star wars i love these things
because like ants their bodies are
segmented into three cubes colored white
and blue are two's colors and you'll
notice their front cube is larger with a
photoreceptor in order to see over their
cargo that they're carrying just like
our two's photoreceptor and then one of
these checks in with r2 they have this
little exchange they android nods just
seems like r2 might be the ant queen of
this colony who runs this hivemind and
yes they are building the jedi school
that we saw in the last jedi flashbacks
the building that they eventually
complete is that same beehive shaped
structure that we saw at the center of
the surrounding additions in dorm huts
that are visible later on the same
school where luke will train his nephew
ben solo before luke freaks out and
scares the [ __ ] out of pen leading to
his defection the kylo ren comics
actually showed that it was not ben who
went on a killing spree and burned down
the temple but instead a bolt of
lightning from snoke
uh palpatine and then ben solo fled and
later on adopted the identity of kylo
ren luke and grogu's meditation session
is introduced with these beautiful shots
of nature swain bamboo light beaming
through the leaves and just gorgeous
music
[Music]
the flute is ludwig gorinson's grogu
theme the music we heard when we first
learned the name of grogu grogo and i
can feel each other's thoughts
[Music]
krogu
gets distracted forced lifting a frog
into his mouth until luke catches him
[Music]
sorry luke in a way mirrors the
demonstration yoda did for him lifting
the entire x-wing from the swamp water
now we gotta say the vfx on luke's face
is a solid improvement this time they
put less of his dialogue on screen in
close up at least at first in the
episode alright let's go for a walk
since mouth movement is really the
hardest part of this animation
reportedly lucasfilm also hired youtuber
shmook who created a much better deep
fake of luke after the mandalorian
season 2 finale mark hamill returns to
voice luke here though it sounds like
they directed him to deliver his lines
in a calmer more zen state in order to
avoid having to animate a lot of facial
emotion this is all just especially
impressive when you realize we're really
just watching two puppets one practical
one digital it all feels like a magic
trick like notice when roku goes from
sitting to standing two stepping all in
the same shot we see freaking daylight
under his body meaning they must have i
guess keyed out the puppeteer or used
vfx to do this the fact that we can't
tell and just assume grogo is a real
living toddler is magic luke tells grogu
about yoda i love how he force lifts him
to keep up his name was yoda
he was small like you
but his heart was huge
he once said to me
size matters not
that's how he talked
he would speak in riddles yes you can
hear john williams yoda theme in there
which always brings tears to my eyes
size matters not is the first time we
see this luke in this episode speak in
close up and yeah it is pretty hard to
animate the impact of the s and the t
consonants which sit at the front of the
mouth especially using your lips and
your teeth however i gotta say it's
pretty clever of them to delay this
close-up until we get to a line that is
a specific meaningful callback to the
original trilogy because mentally all of
us viewing this might be focused less on
the mouth instead thinking back to yoda
and empire in that scene i can't
it's too big
look at me
does mean by my size do you
major props to standard actor graham
hamilton who replaced max lloyd jones
who actually came here last episode as
an x-wing pilot for doing the physical
embodiment of luke skywalker here
hamilton just did a great job capturing
mark hamill's posture from return of the
jedi on this he would speak in riddles
line notice his neck is sloped forward
like he definitely studied the tapes of
hamel on that bridge in endor staple
only directed this episode but it was
written by john favreau and dabeloni
together and i think they might have
written words for luke with easier
consonant sounds to animate relying
specifically on repetition like notice
in this clip have you heard anyone talk
like that back home do you remember back
home that k sound sits in the back of
the mouth uses less of the front part of
the mouth than the lips and the teeth
and then the b and the m really just
require the lips to close so think about
it back home
a lot easier to animate than a t and an
s which are more complex so repeating
the phrase back home back home from our
eyes it's much more lifelike i really do
think they were being strategic about
what words they try to have this puppet
pronounce luke helps grogu remember the
night of order 66 in the jedi temple on
coruscant which ahsoka teased for us
last season on the mandalorian someone
took him from the temple then his memory
becomes
dark here we actually see it from
grogu's point of view all framed in the
cornea of an eye which initially ripples
out from groku on the jungle floor and
then spreads outward to fill the whole
frame telling us that it is really
luke's eye peering into grogu's memory
as the memory begins listen closely
[Music]
yes first we hear the voices of jedi
children suggesting that grogu might
have initially been in the room or
around those young lads that masta
anaken slaughtered or perhaps could have
been in a different padawan class
because we see these three jedi fighting
the 501st clone trooper battalion you
can tell it's them they get the same
blue-plated armor these are the troopers
that anakin led into the temple the best
of the best which is bad news for the
jedi the two jedi on the outside are
robed but based on their hands they do
appear to be adults and the one in the
middle is a man with long blonde hair
tied in a bun he does look a bit like
the jedi temple's battle master sin
dralig who at the time of order 66 was
teaching a class of padawans though it
is believed that innocent skywalker
killed him a security holocron showed
anakin slaying the students of the class
so i'm assuming this guy is probably
someone else we also don't know if these
jedi were aware grogu was behind them
because he does seem to be peering out
from some kind of concealed container i
still think there is some validity to a
theory that i think is crazy but i
really love that grogu could have been
hidden inside of the shell of r2d2 r2
was present at the temple during the
massacre right after the massacre when
anakin brought him back to padme's flat
r2 had some pretty freaked out exchange
with 3po
and notice here that the trooper did not
say grab the kid he just pointed forward
and said go go go let's move i think
these strippers are really just moving
past something something like an
astrobec droid oblivious to what was
hidden inside and during this fight all
the green and blue blades the blue
blaster bolts reflecting grosgu's eyes
as he reacts in terror and his eyes
focus specifically on that green
lightsaber hilt rolling toward him out
of a dead hand it's just also worth
noting that when grogu witnessed luke
saving them with his lightsaber in that
mandalorian season 2 finale the color of
the security camera monitor was shaded
in monochrome grogu did not see that
green blade in action until luke came
through the doors and zipped up the
blade back in the hilt i'm wondering if
grogu may associate a green lightsaber
blade with that trauma from the night of
order 66 and so igniting yoda's saber
might not be the cool toy that grogu
would be that eager to revisit the paint
of and as ahsoka said grog's memory goes
dark at this point he now awakens from
his memory in a totally new location
than where he was before he's now at a
riverbank meaning revisiting that memory
exhausted him into a kind of coma for a
period mano meanwhile wakes up to find
ahsoka tano i'm an old friend of the
family yup me and luke's work criminal
dad used to be tight now concept art in
the credits suggested that mando was
actually gonna instinctively fire at her
but ahsoka might have redirected that
blast using the force i guess like how
we saw kylo ren using the force to stop
a blaster bolt ahsoka says there's
nothing now that will someday be a great
school groga will be its first student
yes confirming that the school that luke
later and ducks his nephew into was
actually initially built to teach grogu
a student who i believe we will learn
will re-buff luke skywalker setting up
luke to not yet learn the error of the
jedi orthodoxy by the time ben defects
but at this point in history luke and
ahsoka are full of optimism there is no
place in the galaxy more safe than here
with luke thank you sure about that
you know what's better than buying stuff
you want getting that same brand new
stuff for up to 90 off the retail price
and that's what you can get with
dealdash the leading pay-to-play auction
site in the united states dealdash has
been in business for over a decade they
auctioned hundreds of brand new items
every day from tvs and laptops to tools
and kitchenware all with guaranteed free
shipping they have a 90 day money back
guarantee on the first bid pack purchase
and you can use it through their website
and through their ios and android apps i
tried my hand at some bidding and it was
a lot of fun i was aiming for this fancy
crossford gaming chair i didn't end up
getting it but i am keeping an eye out
for similar ones in the future all
auctions start at zero dollars each bid
raises the final auction price by one
cent and resets the clocks at 10 seconds
after 10 seconds run out the final
bidder wins and can claim the auction
win by paying the final price you can
always buy your desired items for the
listed price get all your bids back and
use them on another auction use promo
code new rockstars at
dealdash.comrockstars to get 11 worth of
free bids or 30 bonus with your first
purchase when making your first bid pack
purchase don't wait start bidding today
but one of the things that impresses me
most about this episode is the way it
really walks a difficult line with how
much we should trust the jedi way at
this point in history i don't understand
why you're all right with skywalker's
decision to train the kid when you
wouldn't
because it was his choice i don't
control the wants of others yeah that
little sharp exhale from ahsoka reveals
the doubt of one teacher politely
disagreeing with the mentorship agreed
by another like she did not want to
train grogu because she sensed in that
kid the same fear of losing a loved one
that she saw in anakin but luke never
knew anakin is a man before darth vader
just a regretful withered old man under
the armor so luke believes he really can
be the guru that yoda and obi-wan were
to him mando and ahsoka debate over
whether groku should be called a
foundlane or paduan but ahsoka offers to
give grogu the best guard chainmail on
his behalf so grogu won't be distracted
by mando's presence and i love this as
mando takes one last look at grogu
sunlight shines on his shoulder this is
the same sunlight we saw beaming down on
grogu during their meditation through
the bamboo leaves a form of the force
surrounding and comforting them both and
now it gleams on the exact shoulder
where the mud horn sigil is on mando's
armor a sigil that mando chose as a
signet from the moment that grogu used
the force to save him the moment these
two were really fused together as amanda
starfighter departs grogu reaches his
little hand as if trying to muster the
force to force pull his friend back to
him luke works on jumping with grogu
you're trying too hard
don't try
do yes of course recalling yoda's famous
instruction why not
do
oh do not
there is no try luke runs with grogu in
a backpack just like yoda rode his back
during the training on dagobah he does
the same kind of flips he did through
the swamp they climb up a bamboo stalk
and just sway with the breeze crouching
tiger hidden dragon style and he says
wide world exists in balance feel the
force all around you
through the force you will find balance
as well and we hear the french horn of
john williams force theme first heard
when luke gazed out on the binary sunset
of tatooine and suspending them in the
breeze like this is really just a
metaphor for how connecting with the
force is like floating amidst nature the
kind of approach luke takes with rey on
notch toe and between it all
balance luke has grogu balance on one
foot like the awkward handstands yoda
had him do and then later grogu watches
as luke's star wars kids with his
lightsaber the green blade reflecting in
his eyes again just like the sabers did
during order 66. so while he watches
with great interest i really do think
he's associating those two moments luke
uses one of those training remotes to
test grogu's reflexes like obi-wan used
with him on the falcon and a new hope
groku it first rolls it like a ball just
like how we turn that spherical knob on
mando's ship into a bald toy make it
feel especially cruel when this remote
zaps grogu when unlike luke he doesn't
have a lightsaber to deflect it i do
like how this training remote moves with
the same sudden stop-motioning shifts
that it did in 1977 grogu backflips away
from it eventually just straight up
destroying it and drowning it similar to
how grogu has quickly resorted to force
choking in the past getting a head start
on disney doing the same thing to this
actor you taught him well
it's more like he's remembering that i'm
actually teaching him anything
now grogu is over 50 years old the same
age anakin skywalker would have been and
if he had many masters over the years as
ahsoka said roku's jedi training
probably exceeded luke's own ahsoka also
says sometimes the student guides the
master
likely referring to her relationship
with master anakin whom she taught quite
a lot throughout the clone wars they go
on to say sometimes i wonder if his
heart is in it so much like your father
now i assume she's referring to
[Music]
no no i'm just kidding really she sees a
mentor doubting a student just as anakin
would do to her doubt that she would
later prove him wrong on mando returns
to tatooine and joins boba fett finish
shan black santan the mods and the
mayor's major domo at this fun little
moment mayor mark shays is on their
payroll and has flown off world which
leads us to believe
the storm
is about to break it was a scheduled
vacation actually
and you'll notice as they strategize
boba's helmet sits on the throne just a
cool little way of signaling his
authority throughout all of this we see
the skull of the crate dragon that mando
and the tusks and cop vance slayed now
strapped to the roof of a jawa sand
crawler that same great dragon's rib
cage now adorns the interior of the moss
pelgo saloon meaning they had to
disassemble and reassemble it piece by
piece to fit in through the door still i
love that they did this mando asked cobb
banthor some backup mos pelgo might be
good right now freetown
what
it's called freetown now we changed the
name
suits us better that weak wave
proprietor is once again played by w
earl brown who co-starred on hbo's dead
wood alongside timothy elephant the
breeze that we saw in that opening image
on the vapor's fire vein returns hitting
a wind chime signaling cobb to gaze out
on the horizon to see this slender
figure approaching this is just more
great western imagery to introduce this
newcomer teased by the title from the
desert comes a stranger sauntering into
view like david carradine this is cad
bane a duros bounty hunter from clone
wars and bad batch involved in a number
of plots like holding senators hostage
to free the annoyingly voiced zero the
hut
also helping sidious locate a bunch of
force-sensitive kids for a sith army
later on joining the separatists who
would try to assassinate palpatine and
then in bad batch kidnapping omega also
in an unfinished clone wars episode it
was going to be revealed that the dent
in boba fett's helmet was caused by a
duel with cadbane i expect that to come
up next episode along with cadmaine's
past scuffle with fenix shand that we
saw last year on bad match he wears vam
braces on his wrists and he has these
breathing tubes that feed into his
cheeks this is not because he needs him
to breathe normally but to protect him
from getting force choked by a jedi and
i love how his skin is now a paler blue
and wrinkled compared to his animated
form it's a really cool way of showing
how time has dried out this bounty
hunter he says whatever fett is paying
you will match
and all you've got to do is stay put and
let things play out silly and voice work
by corey burton who voiced him on the
animated series this guy's known for his
versatile voiceovers throughout the
disney parks in a number of titles
catband keeps his eyes hidden for most
of the exchange until i'm sorry i didn't
catch your name
i'd be careful where i was sticking my
nose if i were you
these eyes are so effectively alarming
to see in live action signaling the
steely clint eastwoodie anger that cobb
didn't already know who he was and he
drops that great line about his nose
despite cad not having a nose that jumpy
dip bitty scott is played by jj danshaw
who has actually been to wear morrison's
stunt double in past episodes while cad
and cobb remained frozen in this tense
standoff so well edited the deputy
fidgets and shifts his weight around
this is what causes cobb to take his
eyes off cad for just a split second as
the drawing happens but since cad never
took his eyes off cobb he wins a draw
shooting cobb in the shoulder just a
flesh wound but he did shoot him in his
shooting arm a pretty serious injury the
deputy meanwhile he ain't got no respect
i love how afterward joe takes the
fastest glance at the deputy but still
runs over to the marshal i mean i get it
it's a triage scenario but it still
reminded me of those nurses going for mr
burns instead of smithers
two pikes bring a camp tono into garcia
with sanctuary cantina where the usual
faces can be seen there's rhodium
there's an r3x dealer there's an ra7
protocol droid it's a chassis fan
there's a snivian with beautiful hair
maybe she's born with it snivians are a
throwback to a snaggletooth action
figure for kenner modeled on a
background extra that you can see in a
cantina in a new hope but this camp tono
goes boom a classic gang land bombing
like the al capone bombing and the
untouchables as directed by brian de
palma who actually wore the opening
crawl of the first star wars film but i
love this notice how one frame before
that camtono explodes garsa is about to
say something as if she realized a
moment before what was about to happen
now the band in the scene includes that
guitarist and that astromech drummer but
no max rebo what seriously this is some
cersei skip in the sep trial [ __ ] this
guy's got an inside source because
somehow he also survived the explosion
of jabba's got max is [ __ ] in on it
do not join his band cool little detail
in the transition here the flames
transitioned right to luke's finished
school giving this just a few frames
showing that fire blazing up from
beneath the school foretelling this
school's own future fiery end now inside
this temple our shelves contain a number
of artifacts which in the wide profile
shot may include a couple withered books
on that shelf perhaps these are the
sacred jedi texts that luke actually
spent this era of his life tracking down
luke unwraps mando's gift to grogu best
guard chainmail armor knee thrill
actually the framing from luke's
perspective already drapes it over
grogu's body fits like a glove but luke
gives him another option this
is a
it lightsaber to my teacher master yoda
and now
i'm offering it to you
again john williams yoda theme returns
here
and yes i love the return of yoda's
shorter lightsaber first scene an attack
of the clones falling from his hands
during his duel with sidious and revenge
of the sith it was revealed to be
destroyed in darth vader comics number
one however a later comic age of the
rebellion does hint that yoda might have
reassembled the saber when he was on
dagobah so he probably had it with him
on dig about when he died when luke was
there keeping it in that wooden box if
you think about it just like luke's
lightsaber was kept in a wooden box in
maz canada's basement this being a
child's choice between two lives is
another parallel between these series
and lone wolf and cub when a child is
made to choose between the sword and a
toy the path of a warrior or the life of
a normal stupid kid this episode leaves
grogu's choice uncertain but i believe
given how wary this child likely remains
about the danger of green lightsabers
from his most traumatic memory in the
way he reached out for mando i think it
is likelier that he's going to choose
that bescar armor especially when i
think this series is setting him up to
wield the darksaber anyway he is a being
of both mandalorian in jedi custody just
as tar veesla was and bring it full
circle uh that's why poetry arrives but
as we cut to black perhaps my favorite
detail of this episode look very very
closely grogu's mouth begins to open
might be a small detail but the
episode's audio description specifically
call this out i think we cut away right
as grogu was about to utter his first
word what would that word have been i
wonder mando
or maybe he just pukes up like 30 frogs
hey if you live in the chicago area you
gotta come see new rockstars live on
february 11th 8pm talia hall ticket link
in the description we're gonna be doing
some wacky fun stuff that we never do
here on the channel please come out to
meet us you can follow me on instagram
and twitter at eavos follow new
rockstars and subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching
[Music]
you